Das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Noch mal Coffee!
Noch mal Foundation.
Noch mal Joan.
Noch mal 사람들.
so leute am start kann man stream in rechner anmachen rate mal was ich gerade gespielt
habe und wer sofort in game festgestellt hat dass ich in game bin fortnight richtig quatsch
war so ne auch nicht hab bettel viel drei gespielt ich bin auf den server gejoint 200
send crossing am bakils gemacht kam der erste im chat max fps frage zeigt ich weiß nicht
was hier los ist warum die mich doch alle kennen aber man muss ja sagen bettel viel
drei sind wahrscheinlich auch ein paar drauf hängen geblieben und viele haben damals die
videos gekockt bei mir huge terror hat abonniert acht monate prime subscription huge iq subs
subscription hey max bei welcher bank arbeit jetzt sage ich nicht secret wer hat über
morgen noch it abschlussprüfung auf doch gibt es bestimmt ein paar schriftliche prüfung
oder mündlich präsentation
schriftliche prüfung nach der mündlichen prüfung was ist denn das für komische system
sysco final exam welches welches sysco gh1 ist kein problem das kriegst du hin wie um
den wieso teil muss man sich gedanken machen den rest kriegt hin den rest kriegt man hin
der wieso teil ist das problem wegen corona achso verstehe
gegen corona ja das leuchtet ein oder auch nicht
so ja habe ich auch am anfang mal ein bisschen gespielt das war von leuten teilweise mit
entwickelt die auch bei dark age of camelot dabei waren da dachte ich mir so könnt ihr
was werden aber irgendwie aber das pvp nicht wirklich zugesagt in iso
it essentials also first level support au first level support pains champ ich fühle ich
fühle den pains champ gerade massive pains champ übrigens wo habe ich den freund gelesen
das muss ich euch mal zeigen die telekom hier big brain move heute die sind der meinung
wenn man eine geile lichterschau veranstaltet wird der netzausbau besser von das größte
5g netz deutschlands naja ich weiß nicht ob das ein krasses achievement ist wenn man
das größte hat von wenn alle was kleines haben und man hat halt das größte vom kleinen
so weiß nicht ob das wahnsinnig so big brain aber die lichterschau macht es definitiv
besser die musik was bei golem irgendwo habe ich was gelesen ich weiß leider nicht mal
genau was ich mir gedacht habe das muss ich euch zeigen ja das ist das nicht aber das
ist echt wie unbeliebt kann man sich eigentlich machen ja in zeiten wo unternehmen pleite
gehen wo leute kurzarbeit machen müssen wo leute ihre arbeit verlieren wo leute komplett
am existenz unter dem existenz minimum rum krebsen wie dreist kammer oder wie jolo und
scheiß egal weltfremd kann man eigentlich sein dass man auf die idee kommt ein lass
mal rundfunkgebühren erhöhen wie komplett abgehoben detached losgelöst von der restlichen
welt kann man eigentlich sein dass man jetzt die rundfunkgebühren anhebt das leuchtet
mir nicht ein das wollte ich euch aber nicht zeigen ich weiß nicht mehr was also ich bin
immer mehr geneigt dazu mein lastschrift auftrag zu kündigen und am besten noch barzahlung
anzubieten dann bin ich mal gespannt was die machen die können mich ja verklagen wollen
sie mal machen ich gehe ich bezahle ja ihr müsst mir bloß sagen wo was hältst du von
scrum kann bahn etc das kann gut funktionieren wenn man leute hat die wissen was sie machen
und sich nicht zu sehr an irgendwelchen texten die super agile menschen geschrieben am hoch
ziehen sondern die das so machen wie das für das jeweilige unternehmen passt dann kann
das gut funktionieren das problem ist dass die meisten agilen metoden in deutschland
nicht funktionieren oder ich das kamer soll ich sagen also die meisten agilen metoden
in den alteingesessenen unternehmen in deutschland nicht funktionieren scrum wikipedia so weil
das eine der wenigen sachen was sie davon machen also wer sich das hier mal gucken will
das ist ja ein riesen ein riesen sammelsurium an ideen was man machen kann die meisten machen
davon genau zwei sachen irgendeine sprint planung ohne den sprint fertig zu machen und
einen daily stand-up vor allem im kreis stehen und jeder was sagt und komplett entgegen das
der idee hinter scrum läuft es in den meisten alteingesessenen firmen darauf raus dass es
ein tägliches stand-up wird wo derjenige gewinnt der am meisten wichtig tut was er gerade macht
also genau das gegenteil von dem was das eigentlich sein soll sein soll und dementsprechend sagen
viele sie machen es aber die wenigsten machen es wirklich aber das finde ich komplett detached
von der von der realität übrigens das zählen sie remastered lohnt sich richtig ich habe
mir das geholt bin jetzt schon mit der einen kampagne fast durch das macht echt bock das
hat das haben sie mit das ist mal ein richtig gutes remastered hier geworden was sagt ein
hacker news heute habe ich noch gar nicht reingekuckt hacker news ok hacker news mit darkseem sieht
eklig aus end to end encryption für zoom ok auswerb verwendet zoom ja ich weiß genug
aber ich nicht die hacker news ist heute nicht so spannend go generics es wäre wirklich
gut wenn go es mal hier auf die reihe kriegen würde mit generics aber ich glaube da nicht
dran weil die ganzen go profis sind ja der meinung braucht man nicht generics ist komplett
overrated deswegen hat man keine typische renn keine typische renn na keine kütte kein
jetzt habe ich keine typische renn collections in go wo man mehr als ein typ reinpacken kann
weil sowas wie object gibt es ja glaube ich in go gar nicht skype oder teams teams teams
teams teams teams jeden fall teams auf jeden fall teams heute kein big brain chat warum
nicht excellent chat so mal gucken ob ich was übersehen habe oh das chat aufele habe
ich vergessen einzupletten stimmt der chat oje das wichtigste vom ganzen stream oder
ist nicht da wie gesagt ich bin nicht lang eine stunde oder so ungefähr nicht nicht
lang ich wollte eigentlich gar nicht on kommen aber nachdem ich gerade 45 minuten runde irgendwie
war das oder ewig gedauert grand bazaar 64 man rush gespielt habe da war mein hirn so
so kaputt dass ich keine zweite runde mehr hingekriegt hat gibt's gibt's pass of exile
gibt's patch notes gibt's patch notes oh moment das muss ich mal kurz reingucken spielt
von euch einer pass of exile vielleicht ist das ein leak wo ich mal wieder richtig rein
suchte mal gucken mich interessiert eigentlich nur was sie genervt und gebalanced haben an
alle skill balances hier ich kann wieder kein brain dead summoner spielen das ist doch doof
brain dead summoner ist meine lieblingsklasse das kannst du so komplett wie die letzte wieder
letzte kack noob spielen battlefield 6 not a remaster ja das wissen wir ja schon dass
battlefield 6 kein battlefield 3 remaster ist schließt ja der name schon aus ich weiß
ich was jack jack frax uns hierfür big brain gedankengänge erzählen will aber battlefield
3 remaster kann von die namensgebung würde ja noch nicht mal im battlefield kreisend
sinn ergeben wenn man battlefield 3 remaster battlefield 6 nennen würde der lego rasenmeer
können wir uns mal aufregen über die samsung logik bei einigen monitoren warum micharow
weshalb achso du musst den monitor aufmachen um den fuß komplett zu entfernen da muss
ich sagen das haben die richtig gut gemacht bei dem monitor hier das ist ja den ich mir
geholt habe der fuß der fuß den steckst du einfach rein drehst einmal rum er ist dran
das ist total toll und easy gemacht und die haben auch überall so rote markierungen dran
das ist auch nice da kann man innerhalb von 20 sekunden den monitor wieder exakt so einstellen
wie er war das ist echt huge brain okay der matze fragt hey max ich möchte mir ein raid
unter ubuntu einrichten also sorry leute ich muss es korrekt aussprechen also er möchte
sich ein raid unter einrichten performancegründe welches raid würdest du empfehlen falls ich
irgendwann auf 10 g umsteige nutze zurzeit aber nur hdds oder müssen es ssd sein um
die geschwindigkeit zu erreichen das kommt auf die anzahl der festplatten an und ob du
hauptsächlich lesen oder schreiben willst und wie wichtig die ausfallsicherheit ist
also du kannst auch eine raid 1 also wenn die lese performance also sequenzielle lese performance
reicht dann kannst du auch ein paar platten ins raid 1 hängen raid 1 hast du den vorteil
dass du halt dass quasi alle platten bis auf eine kaputt gehen können dafür hast du wenig
speicherplatz und dafür aber ist die lesegeschwindigkeit ziemlich schnell schreiben ist nicht schnell
so die nächste variante war du sagst ok ein bisschen mehr speicherplatz willst du haben
dann kannst du überlegen ob du vielleicht in raid 5 oder 6 machst wobei man da sagen
muss in raid 5 würde ich mit 3 4 platten vielleicht noch machen aber mit mit mehr platten würde
ich eher in raid 6 machen da kriegst du dann auch ordentliche performance raus oder wenn
du sagst ja ich will einen ganz guten kompromiss haben und ein bisschen jolo in kauf nehmen
was kaputt gehen kann dann kannst du auch in raid 1 0 oder in raid 10 machen raid 10
ist eigentlich ganz gut raid 10 hat ziemlich gute performance und raid 10 können bis zu
3 also ne also wenn du glück hast ist bei der bei der dritten platte die kaputt geht
bei 4 erst erst schluss und wenn du pech hast bei der bei der zweiten einen ausfall
hältst du aber auf jeden fall aus ja raid 10 das ist teuer ja allerdings in raid 6 wird
mit großen platten auch relativ teuer ich hatte mal in raid 6 mit damals glaubt waren
das 6 terabyte platten dadurch dann zwei zweimal 6 terabyte und dann irgendwie noch
5 mal 6 terabyte das war auch ganz schön teuer also wenn du mit 4 wenn du 4 platten
hast würde ich mir mal nur raid 10 überlegen mit 4 platten kannst du auch in raid 5 machen
aber da ist die schreibe performance nicht so groß also musst du dir überlegen was
du halt haben willst also lese performance schreibe performance wieviel dürfen kaputt
gehen das kann man so pauschal nicht sagen und eins kann man natürlich unter dem schritt
sagen ssd sind schneller als platten das ist beim raid nicht anders wenn du wirklich 10
g voll kriegen willst dann ja also du wirst vielleicht nicht mit magnetplatten komplett
voll kriegen aber das aber aber in die richtung schon also wenn du wenn du es ordentliche
platten hast machen und du nimmst für nass betrieb 10 terabyte platten was haben die
heute so 250 mb die sekunde 300 mb die sekunde da kriegst du das auch zumindest read performance
mit voll halbwegs so halbwegs da 350 350 oder 300 mal 4 sind natürlich jetzt nicht
du willst nicht extra kriegen und das ist auch nicht ganz 10 g aber fast wirst du nicht
packen aber du kommst in die in die in die richtung ja wann hast du die letzte product
place mit anfrage bekommen laufend allerdings die letzte ordentliche ist schon eine weile
her weil ich mache gerade auf youtube nichts aber ansonsten bekomme ich täglich irgendeinen
müll von irgendwelchen china shops und sonst was ja also wie gesagt du müsstest dich äußern
was du eigentlich genau haben willst da dazu dass man mir sagen kann was hältst du von
der corona ich finde die corona abgeben sich mühe sie geben sich mühe dass was war ich
genau sie geben sich mühe sie versuchen das mögliche transparent zu machen haben sie
auf github sie versuchen das mögliche transparent zu machen sowohl backend als auch abcode ist
auf github wo ich mir nicht wo ich mir nicht sicher bin ist ob mal irgendjemand überprüft
hat ob die ob die ios und die android app auch wirklich die ist die im store ist keine
ahnung und ob die wirklich das im backend einsetzen was hier oben so ist kann man natürlich
letztendlich auch nicht wirklich überprüfen aber sie geben sich wirklich mühe sie sind
auch relativ transparent und sie versuchen es wirklich diesmal ganz gut zu machen nach
dem ersten fiasco mit der mit der app vom robert koch institut das war ja voll von
arsch auf der anderen seite traue ich weder der telekom sap und die kombination sap telekom
bundesregierung wirklich großartig über den weg und ich glaube die einschätzung vieler
leute es verkehrt also wir sind ja gerade aktuell wieder an dem punkt dass leute die corona
app nicht verwenden wollen quasi ausgelacht werden wir so nach den motto ja datenschutz
ist ja gar nicht das problem da muss ich sagen das stimmt die corona app sammelt relativ
relativ wenig war gut die war teuer wie sau die sammelt relativ wenig macht das ganze
anonym also um datenschutz sachen denke ich muss man sich da nicht so viel gedanken machen
eher ob es irgendwelche bluetooth probleme gibt aber das liegt jetzt nicht wirklich an
der corona app ich glaube es liegt an was anderem dass die leute die corona nicht haben
wollen es wurden die letzten jahre so viel internet bzw technikfeindliche politik gemacht
und so viele sachen in den samt gesetzt oder so viel entschieden gegen das was die leute
haben wollten und gleichermaßen gibt es so wenig grundbildung was it anbelangt in deutschland
dass die meisten leute das glaube ich gar nicht richtig einschätzen können also wenn
man die letzten 15 jahre konsequent politik gemacht hat gegen technik gegen internet gegen
so ziemlich alles moderne fängt an mit gesundheitskarte neuem personalausweis bundes treu jahre artikel
13 alles mögliche dann muss man sich nicht wundern wenn die leute einem nicht glauben
dass man in der lage ist so was hinzubekommen und man muss sich nicht wundern wenn die
meisten leute nicht über die notwendigen techniken technischen grundlagen im hirn
verfügen diese sache überhaupt richtig einschätzen zu können du musst dich nicht wundern du
kannst nicht 15 20 jahre lang technik internet alles vernachlässigen und erwarten dass die
leute nicht misstrauisch werden vor allem weil es jede menge sachen gab die auch gegen sie
entschieden wurden da muss man sich nicht wundern also mich wundert es nicht dass viele leute
sagen oh nee die corona will ich mir nicht installieren kann ich nachvollziehen es gibt
jetzt keinen offensichtlichen grund warum man das nicht will wenn man sich das anguckt
aber ich glaube viele leute sind im kopf mittlerweile einfach auf dem stand dass sie sagen alles
was mit technik und sonst was zu tun hat traue ich unserer bundesregierung nicht zu zumal
auch in der vergangenheit vieles gegen uns entschieden wurde wie gesagt richtung bundes
strojaner artikel 13 immer mehr überwachung also sachen die leute eigentlich nicht wollen
störe haftung fürs wlan und das sind alles solche geschichten was halt absolut kein vertrauen
in die in die skills der der entscheidungsträger setzt ja dazu kommt noch was passiert am ende
mit der corona app ja also wenn jemand auf dem handy drauf ist vielleicht kommt dann
jemand auf die idee und sagt das können wir jetzt doch irgendwie als als halben bundesstrojaner
verbrauchen gebrauchen das ist natürlich alles mutmaßung für irgendwo gewisserweise
auch verschwörungstheorie aber ich kann das heute keinem mehr übel nehmen nach 15 jahre
technik internetfeindlicher politik wenn der keinerlei vertrauen darin mehr hat das
hat nix denke ich bei den meisten leuten mit aluhun oder sonst was zu tun den meisten fehlt
einfach die grundlegend technisches verständnis dass sie überhaupt nachvollziehen können was
es überhaupt heißt open source auf github die meisten leute haben doch gar keinen blassen
schimmer geh mal auf die straße und frag jemand was bedeutet es dass die corona app
open source auf github ist so mehr hörst du da nicht du hast keine ahnung das wissen
überhaupt nicht vor wort du sprichst so und nachdem ab nachdem technische grundlagen in
deutschland zum größten teil nicht existieren im kopf der leute wundert mich nicht die denkt
noch irgendwas mit hab das muss porno sein genau die sollen da in seinem stream chat join ja dann
werden sie natürlich big brain das ist klar so deswegen denke ich das hat alles nix damit
zu tun wie die wie jetzt da die teilweise die idioten auf twitter wieder wieder rumlässt
dann so nach dem motto anu trieger verschwörungstheoretiker die leute sind nach 15 jahre technik internet
feindlicher politik einfach total verunsichert und haben kein vertrauen mehr und ich kann
es keinem übel nehmen bei dem ganzen scheiß der da passiert ist in den letzten jahren
das gibt so viel infrastrukturausbau im arsch die ganze störerhaftung geschichte weder
artikel 13 bundesdrujaner gesundheitsakte personalausweis es gibt so viele fail projekte
wo du hinguckst oder oder projekte gegen das was die leute wollen ich nehme es echt keine
mübel wolles sagt er wollte hat jemand auf twitter gefunden der wissen wollte ob das
rechenzentrum iso zertifiziert das exzellente frage huge question so und ja das das ist
der grund warum ich denke man kann es den leuten gar nicht mal so sehr übel nehmen
noch ok wer ist attila hildemanns habe ich noch nie gehört ist er ist ist er eher pok
champ oder eher pains champ wer ist das attila kann man darf man kann man überhaupt danach
suchen ohne dass man jetzt irgendwo rauskommt wo gleich monka monka tos wo habe ich ja monka
tos ist ok veganer aluhut koch ich habe schon mal gesagt wie ich gegen die prinzipielle
einteilung der leute so zu aluhut stehe das kann ich jetzt nicht keine ahnung ich kenne
ihn nicht ich weiß nicht ob es wirklich aluhut ist aber wenn er was von exenmenschen erzählt
dann ist es auf jeden fall aluhut der exenmenschen check ist für mich der aluhut check wenn mir
irgendeiner wirklich erzählen will dass obamas bodyguard exenmensch war dann ist vorbei flach
flacherde ist auch noch flacherde gehen auch noch flacherde ist auch aluhut check ok 5g
und coronamasten ist auch ist auch aluhut check ja das stimmt ja exenmenschen sind auch
das harmloseste ok es gibt genug leute die haben den knall aber trotzdem ich kann es
oft genug sagen auch leute die den knall haben lohnt sich manchmal zuzuhören weil sie was
gescheites sagen können ich kenne den typ nicht keine ahnung ja das bill gates eh an
allem schuld ist ist ja klar läuft läuft eigentlich die corona app auch auf windows
phone nicht cortana app corona app store ok achtung gucken jetzt mal corona ok ich suche
nach corona und finde tres ab rapunzel was ist das für nen dreck igitt was ist das
für den dreck igitt was ist das für nen dreck igitt was ist das für nen dreck igitt
ist das euer ernst ok hat das bewertung reviews oh nee hat es nicht alles klar gehen wir mal
nach corona so finden wir noch so nix na auch gut lats dir runter ne das kommt nicht auf
meine platte wer weiß was da alles drin ist lese mal mein kommentar wo ah schau dir mal
die schweizer app an ist super dezentralisiert und wurde von der etat zürich entwickelt
apple google haben extra dafür eine schrittstelle eingerichtet exzellent ja die schweizer wissen
halt wie es geht die schweizer sind wahrscheinlich schon seit drei wochen fertig damit ist ist
die etat zürich nicht nicht das wo einstein auch war damals hieß es noch ein bisschen
anders aha da sind die schweizer hier sieht doch relativ ähnlich aus zu uns in der android
app na na jéliz apt der android app und ein back-end geschichte ganze Partners ganze java
Ja, ich kann mir aber gut vorstellen, dass die Schweizer das ordentlich hinkriegen.
Schweizer sind erst ergründlich, was sowas angeht.
Basieren die nicht alle auf dem gleichen Prinzip, soweit ich weiß, schon.
Diese ganze Epidemie, Pandemie, AP-Geschichte ist eine Sache, die von Google und Apple bereitgestellt
wird.
Es ist vollkommen egal, welche App man verwendet.
Die App ist im Endeffekt einfach nur Frontend.
Für den ganzen Kram.
Antesten bitte, nee, nee, nee, nee.
Programmier mal einfach, warum sollte ich denn sowas machen?
Wie gesagt, ich habe mich jetzt genug zur Corona-App ausgelassen.
Man sollte, denke ich, trotzdem für Kritik offen sein.
Also, wie gesagt, auch wenn ich denke, dass man die Corona-App relativ bedenkenlos installieren
kann.
Wenn da Leute Kritik dran üben, kann man sich das trotzdem mal anhören, ja.
Ich finde schon, dass es da noch ein paar offene Fragen gibt.
Zum Beispiel, was passiert mit der App nach dem Ablauf?
Also sprich, mit den Installationen, wenn Corona rum ist.
Was passiert damit?
Gibt es da schon irgendwelche Regelungen für?
Wie sieht es aus mit Zwangs-App, wie sieht es aus mit Nachteilen, die man eventuell hat,
wenn man die App nicht verwendet?
Also, es gibt schon ein paar Kritikpunkte, ein paar offene Fragen, die jetzt weniger
an der App selbst liegen, sondern eher halt an dem ganzen Drumherum.
Also, ich denke, es ist sich wert, sich das mal anzuhören, was da Leute, die da Kritik
dran üben, zu sagen haben.
An der App selbst, denke ich, gibt es recht wenig auszusetzen, die macht einen ganz guten
Eindruck.
Installierst du dir die Corona-App?
Nee, kann ich nicht, ich habe ein iPhone 6.
Ich habe ein iPhone 6, kann mir die Corona-App nicht installieren.
Außerdem gehe ich doch eh nicht aus dem Haus.
Wenn ich nicht gerade streame, spiele oder Homeoffice mache, gehe ich höchstens mal
ein bisschen spazieren oder was einkaufen.
Klar, dabei kann auch was passieren, aber ich habe kein Handy, was drauf läuft.
Zumindest nichts, was ich mitnehme.
Doch, ich habe ein neues iPhone, ich habe hier ein iPhone 6 und ein iPhone XS.
Ein iPhone 6 und ein iPhone XS.
Allerdings nehme ich das iPhone 6 mit, weil es leichter ist und da ist die SIM-Karte drin.
Ja, die API, wichtig interessant ist, was mit der Corona-App passiert.
Wie gesagt, ich verstehe Leute, die misstrauisch sind.
Im Hinblick, was mit Bundestrojaner, Artikel 13, alle möglichen Sachen gelaufen sind,
sind die Leute so, okay, was habt ihr eigentlich mit der App vor?
Ich meine, ein Update zu pushen über den App Store, was dann vielleicht die App zweckentfremdet,
ist ja nicht komplett auszuschließen.
Ich sage jetzt nicht, dass es sonderlich wahrscheinlich ist, aber auszuschließen ist das nicht.
Das ist ja fast nichts auszuschließen, deswegen kann ich verstehen, wie gesagt, wenn Leute
kritisch sind dabei.
Ist dann halt dead, wenn die API entfernt wird, warum?
Man könnte doch einfach ein Update pushen über den App Store und dann die App was anderes
machen lassen.
Sei es nur wie Cristiano Ronaldo im Monero-Mine.
Was ist Ripple 20?
Ripple 20, was ist Ripple 20?
Ripple 20 klingt irgendwie ein bisschen, auch nicht.
Das ist wohl wahr, da hat Heise recht.
Internetter Dinge, auch zum größten Teil Internet of Shit.
Ja gut, das verwenden wir alle nicht.
Ich glaube der ESP verwendet, ich weiß nicht, was der ESP für eine TCP-Implementierung
verwendet.
Max, hast du gesehen, dass es ein neues iPhone SE gibt?
Ja all meine Butter, das kann ich verstehen.
Was ist davon betroffen, keine ESPs oder?
Die ESPs haben irgendeine China-TCP-Implementierung wahrscheinlich, die keiner kennt.
Show Dove, Coggers, nice, zwei Monate, danke schön für den Zapp, huge brain subscription.
Ist ESP nicht der Radar-Hack in Shootern, keine Ahnung, nee, das war X22 war das, X22 war
die Geschichte, weiß gar nicht, ob es das noch gibt.
Das trendet eigentlich diese Woche auf GitHub, wo wir gerade mal dabei sind, Explore, Trending,
trending.
Hast du irgendwelche Fragen übersehen?
Nope, habe ich eine XR oder eine XS, ich weiß das nicht, was sind das kleinere davon, XR
oder XS?
XS, dann habe ich wahrscheinlich eine XS, dann habe ich wahrscheinlich eine XS, ich
habe keine Ahnung, ich habe es auch gerade nicht hier, ich weiß es gar nicht, dann habe
ich wahrscheinlich eine XS oder doch eine XR, ich habe keine Ahnung, Hardware wird doch
mehr oder weniger das gleiche sein oder?
Chef-Sessel, das liegt daran, weil die Google-Android-APs kacke sind.
Damit du Bluetooth einschalten kannst, bzw. damit du Bluetooth verwenden kannst, muss
Standortermittlung eingeschaltet sein.
Ohne Standortermittlung erlaubt Google nicht das Zugreifen auf Bluetooth.
Das ist Google-Loyal, da können die Corona-App-Leute tatsächlich gar nichts dafür.
Aber was du machen kannst, ist, du kannst es erlauben und dann GPS einfach global abschalten.
Dann funktioniert das ja ohne keine Orte, aber du kannst natürlich auch kein GPS-Zeug
mehr durchführen.
Warum, das habe ich ehrlich gesagt bis heute nicht verstanden, warum man unter Android
GPS und Bluetooth gekoppelt hat, leuchtet mir nicht ein.
Das ist wirklich richtig low-brain.
Ja, dann sollten sie vielleicht nicht Standortermittlung, sondern sie sollten vielleicht GPS und Bluetooth
trennen.
Sind ja zwei unterschiedliche Varianten zur Standortermittlung, theoretisch kannst du
mit WLAN auch Standort ermitteln.
Du kannst mit erstaunlich vielen Sachen Standort ermitteln und sei es nur die Kombination von
paar Sachen.
Unterhose, äh halt eine Unterhose.
Ohje, das Serious Max schlägt vor, wir sollen dieses Video hier gucken.
Wir haben nicht viel Zeit Leute, wir müssen uns heute die Sachen, die wir uns angucken,
weise auswählen.
Triggert mich das Video, wenn ich sehe.
Der Titel, der Titel ist schon was, wo ich wahrscheinlich wieder richtig drauf abgehen
werde.
Also, man weiß ja, also Leute, wie heißt Faustregel, Handregel, Daumenregel, ne wie
sagt man dann Faustregel, also so genereller Advice von mir, wenn in einem Videotitel oder
auch in Überschriften, wenn in Überschriften, Faustregel genau, wenn in Überschriften
ein Fragezeichen ist, dann ist zu 99 die Antwort nein.
Ihr könnt das ja mal überprüfen und ich sag euch, ihr legt wirklich zu 95% richtig.
Ist in der Überschrift ein Fragezeichen, ist die Antwort darauf nein?
Zu 95% und in dem Fall kann ich die Frage schon beantworten, nein, ist es nicht.
Natürlich, wenn man das weiß, kann man Sachen so formulieren, dass es passt, aber das ist
ja nicht die Absicht von Ihnen.
Okay, okay, wir gucken es uns an, ist gut.
Was ist das für ein beknackter Vergleich?
Also, first zu einem usable desktop, würde ich sagen, ist Linux schneller, die Installation,
wenn man beispielsweise ein fertiges Linux Mint oder Ubuntu nimmt, mit Windows 10, die
Installation ist ungefähr gleich schnell, allerdings muss man unter Windows 10 erstmal
3 Stunden Cortana und Datenschutzgeschiss durchklicken.
Schrei nicht so lauer, Alter.
Die müssen bei allem immer so ein Gefühl von Eile vermitteln in diesen Videos, als
wird es jetzt darauf ankommen, wer schneller was installiert hat.
Okay, aus geht's schon weiter.
Ja, und dafür gibt es keine Spiele, die gescheit laufen.
Okay, es gibt mittlerweile mehr als früher, aber gut ist was anderes.
Ich meine ganz ehrlich, es ist doch vollkommen egal, wie schnell man das installiert, es
macht darüber überhaupt keinen Unterschied, ob man jetzt das Ganze in einer Viertelstunde
installiert hat oder in einer halben Stunde.
Wir sind doch nicht mal zu Windows 98 Zeiten, wo man permanent sein Betriebssystem neu installiert.
Es war vollkommen wurscht, selbst eine halbe Stunde versus zwei Stunden ist doch egal, solange
der Kram nachher stabil läuft und man das damit, was man machen möchte, am besten machen
kann.
Also, wenn man das über den gesamten Steam Spiele-Katalog nimmt und eventuell auch nicht
so anspruchsvoll ist, was RUNS bedeutet, dann mag das rein mathematisch gesehen zutreffen,
eventuell, weiß ich nicht.
Wenn man das allerdings auf große Titel mal einschränkt, also das die Titel, die halt
eben auch Millionen Leute von Rechner locken, nehmen wir mal beispielsweise Fortnite, Warzone,
was auch immer, was gibt's denn da sonst auch, GTA V oder so.
Spätestens bei Multiplayer ist Unterlinux mit Wien halt nun mal Schluss.
Kannst du vergessen.
Ja, du kannst Singleplayer spielen, sehr gut.
Also im Vergleich zu früher, funktioniert die Sache wunderbar, früher haben die Sachen
ja quasi gar nicht funktioniert, mittlerweile sind sie ja schon, mittlerweile ist im Vergleich
zu früher ganz toll, trotzdem, wenn man das mal vergleicht, mit was es alles gibt, ist
es halt trotzdem nicht der Wahnsinn.
End of Function Zero ist bei mir auch so, ich verwende auf der Arbeit auch nur Linux,
daheim hab ich halt hier mein Hybrid aus Windows mit Linux, VM, einzig und allein wegen Spielen
und Video Zeug.
Das habe ich ja auch schon vor zwei Jahren oder so gesagt, dass wenn wir Glück haben,
wird das ganze Cloud-Gaming-Zeugs dazu führen, dass mehr Spiele unter Linux laufen und das
denke ich immer noch, dass das dazu führen könnte.
Ja.
Die sollen Super-Tux-Card spielen, best-scam.
Das stimmt, ja, Emulator-Zeug ist auch absolut kein Problem, ja, das stimmt, da muss man
sich aber ganz genau den Fall angucken, wo das herkommt, es kann nämlich durchaus sein,
dass manche Effekte unter Linux nicht funktionieren und deswegen das Game schlicht und ergreifend
schneller läuft, aber kommt von Fall zu Fall an.
Ja.
Lucky, my car tipped over. In all seriousness though, back when this game came out, I probably would have said, haha, AAA gaming on Linux didn't get real, please.
Es hat sich, es hat sich tatsächlich die letzten Jahre wirklich viel getan.
Yet, here we are.
It's worth pointing out that ACO doesn't work with every game yet, so it's not yet the default.
Huge 60 FPS. Das ruggelt. Die spielen doch bestimmt 4K, das kann sein.
Allerdings, wenn ich die Auswahl hätte zwischen 4K oder flüssigen FPS, würde ich immer flüssige FPS nehmen.
Ja.
Besten Grafik-Driverunterdienung sind tatsächlich Intel, aber Intel GPUs sacken halt.
Warum verwenden die nicht CAC-FPS? Oder wie haben wir unser Tool genannt?
FPS-CAC? Oder irgendwie sowas? Die sollen CAC-FPS verwenden. Das beste Tool dafür.
Das beste Tool dafür.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich ein riesen Vorteil, den man oftmals unter Linux hat.
Wenn der Kram unterstützt wird, dann geht er meistens einfach, ohne dass man großartig was machen muss.
Problematisch wird's, wenn's nicht funktioniert.
So.
Absolut nicht gestellt.
Ja, warum nicht?
Das ist das Allerwichtigste. Das Allerwichtigste. Wenn RGB nicht geht, hat man schon mal 20 FPS weniger.
Das kann ich verstehen. Das ist ganz essentiell.
Ja, das kann ich verstehen.
Okay, Hotshot. Wie geht's mit VR, wenn ich in den Beat Saber Action Penguin Edition gehen will?
Das ist schwierig. HTC Vive und Valve Index haben schon lange gearbeitet, weil Valve sie in Steam offiziell unterstützt.
Aber der OpenHMD-Driver für Oculus und PSVR gibt es gerade nicht. Und die Virtual Desktop Experience und die Re-Projection sind bezeichnet als große Probleme für alle Linux-VR-User.
Das ist ein echtes Bummer, weil ich Virtual Desktop sehr oft benutze, auch wenn es nur um meine Streams zu machen, während ich spiele.
Ja. Ja.
Es gibt halt ein paar Sachen, die für viele Leute absolut Killer sind. Die brauchen sie.
Wie gesagt, wenn mein Zeug alles, was ich machen will, unter Linux funktionieren würde, da würde ich doch kein Windows mal verwenden. Wozu sollte ich das denn machen?
Ich bin noch nicht bescheuert. Aber leider ist das halt aktuell noch nicht so.
Ja, gut.
Ja, seit 10 Jahren. 15 Jahren.
Ich scheiße auf die Hardcore-Linux-Fans. Ganz ehrlich. Die haben auch in der Vergangenheit gesagt, dass zum Beispiel Plug and Play komplett useless ist.
Wer möchte denn bitteschön, dass der Rechner was automatisch macht? Ich möchte das alles von Hand vergeben. Da gibt es öfters gibt es tonnentausende Diskussionen von irgendwelchen Hardcore-Linux-Fans, die immer mit anfangen, das braucht man nicht, das ist doch für Noobs und sonst was.
Dann sollen sie Gentoo verwenden und erstmal 45 Minuten kompilieren, wenn ihnen einer einen Anhang für Open Office schickt. Meinetwegen. Alles okay.
Und desto mehr die Userbase wächst, desto mehr accessible wird alles. Also, an diesem Punkt ist der Call-to-Action für euch wirklich einfach. Wo geht es hin? Ah, da ist es.
Hardcore-Linux-Fans spielen SuperToxCard. SuperToxCard, bestes Game.
Ohne SuperToxCard geht da nichts. Machen wir eine Runde. SuperToxCard, exellent.
Wir fahren eine SuperToxCard. SuperToxCard. Jetzt habe ich Linux-Gaming. Huge Linux-Gaming.
Oh, what? Ah, exellent, da darf man natürlich nicht reinfahren. SuperToxCard. Huge. Massive, Massive-Gamer.
Linux, eindeutig beste Gaming-Plattform. Ich meine, wer, wer, wer braucht denn bitteschön was anderes, wenn er SuperToxCard hat? Insane.
Ja. Ist Wubblos ein guter Streamer? Nee, auf keinen Fall. RGB-Klo. Mein Klo hat eine blaue LED, die angeht, wenn man sich draufsetzt, dass man nachts ein bisschen was sieht.
OlaVentures hat gesagt, zwei Monate. Exellent. Da muss ich auch Prime suppen bei ihm wieder. Exellent-Subscription. Dankeschön. RGB-Klo haben wir schon.
Äh, ja wie hieß das Tool nochmal? Hat jemand gemerkt, wie das Tool hieß? Ich kann mir das gerade mal angucken. OpenRGB oder irgendwie sowas, ne? Was da?
Oh, GitLab. Das ist wieder irgendeiner, die Hälfte auf GitLab umgezogen hat. Aurora. Das hab ich sogar schon mal ausprobiert. Das war wirklich ganz gut. Die ist außerhalb vom Klo. End of Function Zero.
Das hab ich sogar schon mal ausprobiert. Das ist wirklich ganz gut gewesen. Allerdings haben sie damals, glaube ich, nicht mein Corsair Keyboard unterstützt. Aber hab ich jetzt ja nicht, weil ich hab jetzt nur Logitech.
Müssen wir echt mal ausprobieren. Aber ich hab ja kaum noch RGB. An der Maus hab ich die Beleuchtung komplett aus und an der Tastatur hab ich konstant auf Blau stehen.
Ey, Choose By Name vergiss es. Ich hab eine Sache bisher gemacht mit GTK unter Windows und es ist einfach grausam, bis das funktioniert. Grausam. Zumal man auch die MSYS 2 GTK Libraries gar nicht richtig verwenden kann, weil man braucht unter Windows in der Regel keine GCC Libraries, sondern Visual Studio C Compiler Libraries.
Und das sind die MSYS 2 GTK Pakete nicht. Es ist voll für'n Arsch, GTK unter Windows. Das nächste Problem, was du hast, ist, wenn du startest, dass GTK der Meinung ist, seinen eigenen Fensterrahmen malen zu müssen, der überhaupt nicht aussieht wie Windows.
Das muss er dann erstmal in zig Konfig-Sachen ausstellen, dass er das macht. Richtig hängen geblieben. So, ich wollt mal gucken, was gerade auf GitHub trendet. Wir sind ja leider, haben auch nicht so viel Zeit. Was trendet denn auf GitHub this Week?
YOLO V5. Was ist YOLO V5? YOLO V5, PyTorch und CoreML iOS. Ich hab legit keinen Plastenschimmer. Irgendwas Chinesisches.
YOLO V5, YOLO VL, YOLO V5M, YOLO V5. Object Detection Methods. Ah, das könnten sie vielleicht da oben hinschreiben, dass man weiß, was es ist.
Vanilla Web Projects. Das könnte ein gutes Beispiel sein für Leute, die im Stream immer fragen, mit welchem Programmierprojekt soll ich anfangen.
Li-Han-Code. So viel chinesische Sachen auf GitHub. Jason for Modern C++. Ok, ich will mich gerade mal schocken, Leute. Wie macht man Jason in Modern C++? Example.
Ja, sieht schon mal ganz toll aus. Example. Example. Tja, wenn man keine ordentlichen Escaped Strings hat in der Programmiersprache, dann sieht das halt so aus.
Haben wir hier einen Examples Ordner? Nee. Das ist auch so was, was mir in C++ Projekten oftmals auf den Keks geht, dass die keinen Examples Ordner haben.
Ok. Ah ja. Es sieht relativ normal aus. Gar nichts, wo ich mich jetzt wahnsinnig drüber beschweren könnte.
Jason Pointer. Es sieht halt relativ normal aus. Außer, dass wieder so komische Sachen da drin sind, aber gut.
Es sieht nach einer halbwegs brauchbaren Jason Library für C++ aus. Tja, gut. Warum nicht?
Was haben wir sonst noch hier? Playwright Node Library to Automate Chrome Webkit. Ok, das ist für Leute, die kein Puppetier verwenden wollen und alle Browser automatisieren wollen. Ok.
Go Plus Language for Data Science. Ok, es ist Go mit Zusatz Go. Double Go.
Irgendwie ist diesmal nichts Spannendes drin. Samarine Farms ist auch was da. Marsch den großen Bogen drum.
Irgendwie nichts Spannendes drin diesmal. Na ja, kann ja immer was drin sein. So, ähm, gucken.
Pepega Board. Präprozessor Brainfuck. Äh, Brainfuck gebe ich heute nicht. Kennst du Django? Ja, kenne ich. Ich habe aber nie was mitgemacht.
Das einzige was ich zu Django, was mir da spontan einfällt ist, dass sie hier so ein eingebautes Dashboard Zeugs haben.
So. Ja Leute, gibt es noch irgendwas? Ich muss gleich auf. Ich habe ja gesagt, nur eine Stunde ganz ganz kurz erstrieben, weil ich keinen Bock mehr hatte auf noch eine Runde Grand Buzzer 64 Spieler.
Mit massig vielen Tickets. Habe ich hier was im Chat übersehen? Nö, sieht nicht so aus.
Pepe Fett. Wann ist das Apple Event? Ich glaube nächste Woche. War heute oder Morgen Nacht Wahl EA Play. Kann das sein?
Apple ist nächste Woche. Ne, Morgen Nacht. Moment, ist das heute Nacht? 1 Uhr? Oder ist das Morgen Nacht 1 Uhr? Das EA Play Event.
Aber das ist mir zu spät. Das strebe ich nicht. 1 Uhr Freitag, okay. Ne, das ist mir zu spät. 1 Uhr Freitag bedeutet ja der Freitag kommt noch und ich muss arbeiten.
Tschüss man ey, mich wundert nichts mehr. Das ist nächste Woche. Die Apple Geschichte. Das gucken wir uns an zusammen. Ob da wieder Monitor-Ständer für 1000 Euro präsentiert werden.
Apple streben ich ja. Mehr an die IAK. Ah ne, das habe ich nicht an die IAK. An den U-Form Verlag. Mach ich noch. Echt mal gespannt was die antworten.
Hattest du damals explizit für den Visoteil deiner Prüfung gelernt? Ja, ich habe halt fertige Prüfung gemacht. Da war auch Visor dabei.
Ne, habe ich nicht gesehen. Aber ich glaube ich kenne das. Die Story mit der Wiese. Die heute ganz anders aussieht. Ich habe halt ganz normale Prüfung gemacht.
Da war halt der Visorteil mit dabei. Ich habe einen großen Pogen um die ganze Visor-Geschichte gemacht. Ihr wisst, ich halte von BWL-Geschichten. Ist nicht mein Fall.
Wie stehst du zu Rechnungswesen? Naja, ich habe mal gelernt, wie man eine Bilanz macht und wie man Zeugs bucht von Hand. Aber nicht, dass es mir gefällt.
Das muss echt nicht sein. Ich weiß noch, wie man diesen Saldo Strich macht. Man musste doch, Leute, wenn man so ein T-Konto hat, da musste man doch, wenn unten Platz auf der Seite ist, ein Strich drunter machen oder so.
Kann das sein? Das musste man doch irgendwie so entwerten. Und das musste genau so sein, sonst geht es nicht.
Ah, BWL-Zeug. Hör mal auf. Die Buchungsnase. Heißt das wirklich die Buchungsnase? Heißt das wirklich Buchungsnase? Tatsächlich. Fuck, das heißt Buchungsnase. Die Buchungsnase.
Guckt es euch an. Ja, den Scheiß habe ich mal gelernt, wie man das macht. Für alle, die es nicht gemacht haben, ihr habt absolut nichts verpasst.
Das größte Scheiß überhaupt. Richtig dumm. Also zumindest nichts für mich. Was zum Teufel ist ein T-Konto? So was hier. So was hier soll haben.
Konto 1, Konto 2. So was da. Das ist ein T-Konto. Will man nicht wissen. Glaubt mir, will man eigentlich gar nicht wissen.
Ist wirklich so eine Sache. Die habe ich zwar mal gelernt, aber ich bin froh, dass ich damit nichts zu tun habe.
Ne, da bin ich froh, dass ich nichts mehr damit zu tun habe. Am Freitag ist Prüfung. Danach enthiert es sich fast nicht mehr. Das ist zu spät. Bis zum Freitag schaffe ich es bestimmt nicht, darauf zu antworten.
Aber nächstes Jahr ist auch wieder Abschlussprüfung. Wobei, ne, dieses Jahr ist sogar noch Weihnachts-Abschlussprüfung oder Winter-Abschlussprüfung.
Nun ja Leute. Es ist 22 Uhr. Ich habe ja gesagt, heute nur ganz kurzer Stream. Was sagst du zum Altersunterschied im Zusammenhang mit Lohn?
Was soll ich dazu sagen? Ja, was soll ich dazu sagen? Keine Ahnung.
Ich meine, wenn es dazu führt, dass die Leute dann auch die Sachen besser können. Mehr Erfahrung haben. Oder im Zweifelsfall, wenn es einfach nur im Tarifvertrag steht. Warum nicht? Ist doch okay.
Ja, das liegt wahrscheinlich daran, weil es entweder im Tarifvertrag steht. Wenn du dich damit nicht abfinden willst, kann ich das auch verstehen.
Da sag ich, ich sehe es nicht ein. Da habe ich mir ehrlich gesagt auch keine Gedanken zugemacht bis jetzt. Da habe ich mir noch nie Gedanken zugemacht, ob ich das gut oder schlecht finde.
Wobei mehr Geld eigentlich immer gut ist. Aber im Zweifelsfall wird es eher dazu führen, dass nicht du mehr kriegst, sondern alle weniger. Also wenn sich das so durch die Bank durchsetzen würde.
So Leute, ich bin müde. Ich gehe jetzt pennen. Wir sehen uns bis morgen. Oder so. Mal gucken. Bis der NCU.